joshua is with us joshua is in
fredericksburg
virginia how are you joshua hey dave i'm
doing great how are you doing
better than i deserve how can i help so
i just have a quick question um
i'm relatively new to your show but i've
been watching a lot of clips
and uh i'm on my way i'm on baby step
number one getting my money put away in
savings
um i want to ask a question about when
i'm moving full force onto step two
i want to ask your advice on i have the
opportunity
to act as a private auction so i can
flip a few cars a year
um and i wanted to know uh if you agree
with stuff like
you know spend money to make money type
side gigs where i
can buy cars and flip them in the
process of paying off debt
to you know help me get more profits
overall and pay things off quicker
are you doing that with cash
yeah well so instead of just putting it
full force on the debt i would put cash
aside to
buy cars on the cheap and then flip them
when you buy the car you're paying cash
for the car
yeah that's what i mean okay so give me
an example
you would buy a car you buy a car for
how much and flip it for how much
so i could probably get a car for two
grand and easily flip it for four to
five
um because like i said i have private i
have access to a private auction so the
cars are a lot cheaper than anyone
you know a public auction or anywhere
else
[Music]
okay and um
and what do you make of your day job
uh about 33 grand i just started up a
new job okay
all right and how much debt do you have
so i have around 14k in debt okay
cool yes i would do that now here's
let's think let's think through some
guidelines
because as you know you can get sucked
into this
um and i you know you could start
you could put all the money back in and
all this kind of stuff and then you
then you ended up benefiting your debt
payoff not at all
but you sure didn't get into a bunch of
cars okay so we don't want to do that so
it's
one at a time and
you'd take you know you say i'm gonna
okay i'm gonna put some
seed money in or prime the pump if you
will and so we're gonna set two thousand
bucks in
and then you buy that car and you flip
it for
3 500 and you pull the 2000 out to do
the next deal
keeping it there but the anything above
the 2000 goes on the debt every single
time
everything above the 2000 goes down to
the debt
not okay don't buy a 2200 car
or a three thousand dollar car the next
time you're buying a
two thousand dollar car every time or
whatever your
your baseline is but you what can happen
is
emotionally you get more caught up in
doing the deals than you do
actually causing the deals to benefit
you and you go well you know
i you know if gosh if i turn the 2000
into three i could turn a three into six
and then i could turn a four into eight
and then you get sucked into this vortex
and all the money's pouring back into
this system you're building
rather than in getting out of debt does
that make sense
yeah yeah absolutely i get you i didn't
even think about that and knowing me
i would fall into that for sure well
you're a player that's how i know to get
warn you against that because i'm a
player it's the kind of thing i do
and so i have to watch against it and
car auction directors
love players because they say man if you
just go to five on this you can you can
flip this for 14
3 easy and it's just hard hard you have
to be disciplined right
yeah you really have to be disciplined
that's the purpose of an auction is to
take advantage of undisciplined people
or to pit disciplined people undisputed
people against each other
yeah exactly and then you get then all
of a sudden there's no room in the deal
because you've overpaid that's what you
get into but yeah give yourself some
real strict
business operational guidelines if you
will like i just laid out
something like i laid out and then every
time stick to them don't let your
uh don't let the uh the greed on one
shoulder talk you
into losing your common sense on the
other shoulder and if there's no two
thousand dollar deals to be had this
particular saturday go home you walk
away go home you'll walk away that's
exactly right that is a good plan